zone Europe sur sensation
bonsoir et bienvenue dans zone Europe
sur Radio sensation une émission
enregistrée au Parlement européen de
Strasbourg et en association avec tv78
un flashback pour commencer retour sur
le parcours de Nicole Fontaine la occupé
la présidente du Parlement européen de
1999 à 2002 avec Marie Raphaël minier du
Centre Europe Direct de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye l'une des lignes
de force qui composent cette nouvelle
conscience collective européenne et
celle d'une vision éthique de l'Union
aujourd'hui l'Europe a un besoin vital
de ne plus être seulement une Europe
économique Nicole Fontaine
la deuxième femme présidente du
Parlement européen était une responsable
politique persuasive et une ardente
promotrice de l'Europe qui supervise à
l'adoption de l'euro Nicole Fontaine qui
fut présidente de 1999 à 2002 s'employa
à réformer les méthodes de travail du
Parlement européen afin de rapprocher
l'institution des citoyens Nicole
Fontaine est né le 16 janvier 1942 à
Grainville immobile en Normandie fille
de médecin et petite fille instituteurs
elle fait des études de droit et devient
membre du Barreau du département des
Hauts-de-Seine elle vit dans le quartier
Latin à Paris lors des émeutes des
étudiants et des travailleurs en 1968
elle vient de terminer ses études à
l'Institut d'études politiques de Paris
et attend son premier enfant
ce décrivant davantage comme une
observatrice que comme une participante
aux événements elle dira plus tard que
les manifestations de Mai 68 ont
accéléré un changement inévitable dans
la société française elle débute sa
carrière au secrétariat général de
l'enseignement catholique où elle est
chargée des relations entre le secteur
de l'enseignement privé et les pouvoirs
publics elle est membre du Conseil
supérieur de l'éducation nationale de
1975 à 1980 et du Conseil économique et
social de 1980 à 1984 elle gagne en
visibilité lors des débats nationaux sur
l'enseignement privé et est élu au
Parlement européen en juin 1984 dès le
début de sa carrière parlementaire
Nicole Fontaine œuvre pour une robe des
citoyens en se concentrant sur des
projets liés à l'éducation à la
reconnaissance mutuelle des
qualifications universitaires et à
l'égalité homme-femme elle occupe la
fonction de vice-présidente à deux
reprises de 1989 à 1994 puis de 1994
1999 elle négocie des accords entre le
Parlement européen et les États membres
sur des actes législatifs essentiels
dont deux programmes en faveur de la
jeunesse socratesse et jeunesse pour
l'Europe en 1999 theaconomiste la décrit
comme une conciliatrice qui cherche à
dégager des consensus et à construire
des coalitions qu'il n'est nulle part
plus à l'aise que dans les couloirs de
l'Europe sollicitant l'appui de tous les
partis avec le sourire Nicole Fontaine
était lui présidente du Parlement
européen le 20 juillet 1999 son premier
test est la nouvelle nomination d'une
commission présidée par romano-prody à
la suite de la chute de la commission
Santerre en mars 99 elle entretient de
bonnes relations avec la nouvelle
Commission et les États membres au sein
du Conseil des ministres
oeuvrant sans relâche pour le dialogue
et la paix Nicole Fontaine parvient à
réunir les présidents des parlements
Palestiniens et Israéliens pour une
poignée de mains historique en 2000 en
2001 elle invite le commandant Massoud
vice-président de l'Afghanistan à venir
à Strasbourg pour parler de la situation
de son pays elle s'inquiète en
particulier du sort des femmes afghanes
le mois suivant trois femmes qui se sont
échappées de Kaboul témoignent au
Parlement européen elle décrit la
Réunion comme l'un des moments les plus
émouvants de sa présidence en 2002 elle
quitte le Parlement européen pour
devenir ministre de l'Industrie dans le
gouvernement français de Jean-Pierre
Raffarin entre 2004 et 2005 elle dirige
la Fondation cell qui lutte contre
l'exploitation sexuelle
elle a également écrit plusieurs livres
sur le travail du Parlement européen
elle participe activement au débat afin
d'améliorer l'Union européenne jusque
dans les dernières années de sa vie
juste avant le référendum britannique
sur l'appartenance à l'Union européenne
en juin 2016
elle publie l'ouvrage brexit une chance
repenser l'Europe avec le journaliste
français François poulet Matisse qui
porte un regard objectif sur les raisons
de la désaffection des citoyens envers
l'Union européenne défendant toujours
l'Europe elle examine les moyens d'en
faire des possibilités de répondre aux
besoins de ses citoyens elle décède en
2018 à l'âge de 76 ans son attachement
aux idéaux européens a été récompensée
de son vivant par un certain nombre de
prix notamment la médaille Robert
Schuman et la médaille de Commandeurs de
l'ordre national du Mérite
zone Europe l'invité politique
[Musique]
bonjour Pierre laroutot bonjour vous
êtes heureux député membre du groupe de
l'Alliance progressiste des socialistes
et des démocrates au Parlement européen
et vous êtes membre de la commission des
budgets on va parler avec vous
aujourd'hui d'un projet qui vous révolte
le projet de Total ecope c'est comme ça
qu'on les nomme une des plus grandes
entreprises françaises totales qui est
spécialisée dans le domaine de l'énergie
[Musique]
Strasbourg ou à Paris on voit que des
énergies renouvelables mais en fait 75%
des investissements aujourd'hui de total
c'est dans les énergies fossiles alors
que il y a un an vous en souvenez
c'était à l'une des échos le l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie disait que
si on veut éviter un avenir
apocalyptique il faut stopper
immédiatement tous les nouveaux forages
de gaz et de pétrole cet été en France
on a eu trois canicules on a eu plus de
10000 morts on a eu des feux de forêts
en Bretagne quand j'étais petit personne
pensait qu'on aurait des feux de forêts
en Bretagne il y a eu des inondations
catastrophiques au Pakistan ou en Inde
voilà donc tout le monde se demande
comment stopper le dérèglement
climatique tout le monde sait y compris
en Ouganda et en tant d'années qu'on
peut faire des énergies renouvelables
mais malgré tout malgré tout total
continu à faire des investissements
fossiles et ce sont les pires je sais
pas si on peut faire un zoom là-dessus
ça c'est l'ensemble des 8 plus grandes
mijores pétrole et gaz au niveau mondial
elle continue tout un peu les
investissements fossiles mais la numéro
1 pour le pétrole et pour le gaz dans
les quatre années qui viennent c'est
total donc c'est vraiment scandaleux et
ce projet à noganda il y a déjà 20
banques qui ont dit non ce projet
tellement catastrophique pour le climat
pour la biodiversité ils vont faire des
forages le plus beau parc naturel de
Ganda vous avez des girafes des lions
des éléphants et c'est là qu'ils veulent
commencer à la fin de l'année des
forages il y a 100 000 personnes qui
sont concernées des paysans souvent
total leur demande de ne plus exploiter
leur terre normalement mais ça fait 4
ans qu'ils attendent de l'argent donc
j'ai vu on a passé 9 jours en Ouganda
nous cet été on a vu des enfants qui
vont plus à l'école depuis 4 ans parce
que les parents n'ont plus de quoi vivre
et n'ont plus de quoi payer l'école donc
c'est juste un scandale à tout point de
vue on n'est pas les seuls à se révolter
il y a déjà 20 banques qui ont dit non
la Deutsche Bank a dit non BNP a dit non
Barclays a dit non et puis vous l'avez
dit il y a un mois le Parlement européen
quand on est revenu de Ganda on a fait
voter par l'ensemble de ce Parlement une
résolution pour dire STOP ecope stop ce
projet stop définitivement les forages
dans le parc naturel et stop pendant un
an tout le projet pour réfléchir à des
renouvelables et donc maintenant le but
est de mettre la pression sur total mais
aussi sur le Crédit Agricole et sur
Amundi qui sont ses principaux
actionnaires justement de multiples
recours judiciaires sont en cours de la
part de engie française et ou notamment
les Amis de la Terre ou en sont les
recours aujourd'hui et est-ce qu'ils
peuvent vraiment faire donc changer
cette décision du gouvernement ougandais
qui est tout de même souverain sur sur
ces terres bien sûr le One morgandé est
souverain et je suis en contact avec des
ambassadeurs avec des parlementaires on
va tout faire pour leur montrer c'est un
point fondamental parce qu'il s'agit pas
de stopper le pipeline et que ce soit
des Chinois ou des Américains qui le
reprennent donc aussi y compris les
arguments de Toto d'ailleurs quoi qu'il
arrive le projet se fera et si c'est pas
nous ce sera d'abord des entreprises
chinoises ou américain
est arrivé à la Maison Blanche je dois
dire une signe pour dire les États-Unis
reviennent à l'accord de Paris et 5
minutes après Joe Biden signer un décret
pour dire on stoppe le pipeline question
XL vous êtes voilà donc il y a une
cohérence en principe et d'ailleurs il y
a quelques jours Emmanuel Macron était
sur France 2 on lui a demandé est-ce que
vous soutenez ce pipeline il a dit que
la France ne le soutenait oui mais en
fait c'est ambigu il a pas dit non plus
qu'il voulait l'arrêter donc nous le
Parlement la position du Parlement
européen est très claire on veut stopper
ce pipeline et comme un des responsables
du budget j'ai été rapporté général du
besoin en 2021 je vais tout faire pour
qu'il y ait de l'argent mis sur la table
parce que l'Ouganda au début ne voulait
pas ce projet c'est total c'est le
patron de Total pour y aller qui a
convaincu monsieur Moussier vini le
président ougandais et pourquoi est-ce
que le gouvernement Gambetta est
intéressé en l'air un parc
naturel c'est pas leur objectif faire du
pétrole pour le reste du monde qui va
polluer la planète c'est pas leur
objectif mais le Ganda a besoin d'argent
et on peut très bien le comprendre le
grand a besoin d'argent pour un système
d'éducation nationale qui soit gratuit
aujourd'hui l'éducation est payante en
Ouganda et le gouvernement voudrait un
système gratuit bravo et un système
d'électricité ils auront bientôt trop
d'hydroélectricité et des grands
barrages ils ont bien de faire un réseau
électrique donc je pense qu'on peut très
vite arriver à un accord entre l'Union
européenne et l'Ouganda en disant si
vous renoncez à ce pétrole on vous met
de l'argent sur la table pendant 25 ans
et c'est pas moi qui a eu l'idée en
termes de développement notamment en
terme d'aide au développement mais avec
de laitiers 100% des dons et pas des des
prêts et en fait l'idée n'est pas de moi
c'est en
c'était le patron de l'Équateur le
président de l'équateur Raphaël Korea
qui a vu une idée assez géniale Raphaël
Correa président de l’équateur et fait
un très beau discours en disant j'ai du
pétrole dans mon sous-sol je peux y
renoncer si on me donne de l'argent en
compensation et au bout de trois ans ils
avaient négocié avec les Nations Unies
vous voyez la le symbole de l'équateur
et des Nations Unies un accord
passionnant très très concret sur
comment on vérifie qu'on a stoppé le
pétrole combien on a d'argent comment on
contrôle que l'argent ne va pas dans la
poche de quelques-uns mais va pour le
bien commun qu'est-ce qu'on fait sur la
biodiversité sur l'éducation sur les
services publics donc l'accord signé par
l'équateur et les Nations Unies peut
nous servir de modèle à l'époque il y
avait pas eu d'argent mais encore hier
j'étais en échange avec une quelqu'un
qui était ministre à l'époque et qui dit
peut-être qu'on avait 15 ans d'avance
mais que maintenant 2022 les gens ont
compris l'urgence donc voilà encore je
suis un peu soufflé enfin je sors d'une
autre réunion mais encore hier matin à
9h du matin je plaidais pour que on
trouve les moyens budgétaires très vite
de dire à l'Ouganda on n'est pas là pour
vous donner des leçons c'est vous qui
décidez mais en Ouganda aussi il y a du
dérèglement climatique le tous les jours
qu'on est arrivé à Kampala elle a une
des journaux c'était 900 morts à cause
de la sécheresse voilà très concrètement
le jour on est arrivé à Kampala avec mes
collègues députés 900 morts dans le nord
de l'Ouganda à cause de la sécheresse et
le dernier jour 30 morts à cause des
inondations donc en Ouganda aussi ils
veulent lutter contre le dérèglement
climatique la question intervalle que
l'Europe fait du blabla est-ce que
l'Europe donne des leçons de morale ou
est-ce que l'Europe est capable de
sortir le chéquier pour une nouvelle
coopération vous l'avez dit donc le
Parlement européen a adopté cette
résolution dénonçant ce projet
d'extraction pétrolière en Ouganda
c'était le 15 septembre dernier mais
total répond donc l'entreprise n'a pas
été sollicitée avant l'adoption de cette
de cette résolution et qu'elle n'a pas
pu se défendre au Parlement européen le
PDG de Total a donc décidé de ne pas se
rendre à une autre audition qui était
prévue le 11 octobre cette fois par la
Commission des droits humains du
Parlement européen cela fait pourtant un
bon moment que vous essayez de de
problèmes de rapport à la vérité je vais
pas dire qu'il ment mais ça il ressemble
beaucoup d'abord à titre personnel et
avec un des plus grands climatologues
français Jean Josel à trois reprises on
a demandé à Monsieur pouyanet une
rencontre depuis le mois de mai il y a
une fois on arrive au pied de la tour
total on arrivait aussi à les au total à
Paris enfin la défense et là le
conseiller politique de bouyanais me dit
que le rendez-vous est annulé parce que
ce que j'ai dit sur les réseaux sociaux
a beaucoup énervé monsieur puni voilà
mais donc en tout cas à trois reprises
on a demandé rendez-vous et on était
même physiquement au siège total et
après ça avec nos collègues députés on a
passé 9 jours en Ouganda et à trois
reprises on a rencontré les dirigeants
de Total Ouganda le cinquième jour on a
passé trois heures plus de trois heures
avec les sites dirigeants de Total
Ouganda à Kampala au siège de Total en
Ouganda le lendemain on a passé trois
heures avec les dirigeants de total pour
nous qui voulaient nous montrer les
travaux donc au total on a passé plus de
7 heures ou de huit heures avec les
dirigeants de Total Ouganda donc on a
demandé rendez-vous à Monsieur pouillané
lui-même à pouvoir le voir dans son
siège social on a passé plus de 7 heures
ou 8h avec les dirigeants au total on a
voté cette résolution c'est sans doute
qu'on a de bons arguments si nos
collègues députés même ceux qui
n'étaient pas venus on a montré des
vidéos qui montrait de gravité de ce
qu'on a vu et entendu c'était terrible
c'est pas pour rien si le Parlement
aussi vite à voter une résolution aussi
forte et après ça si monsieur pouyanais
était fier de ce qu'il fait s'il n'avait
pas de problème pour répondre à nos
questions il serait venu devant le
Parlement on voulait lui consacrer une
heure et quart on reçoit tous les jours
des demandes de patron ou de
syndicalistes qui veulent être écoutés
par le Parlement européen Rosa donc en
général quand on propose à quelqu'un
d'avoir une heure et quart devant des
députés il est chouette j'ai plein de
choses à vous dire donc si monsieur
pouyanais a refusé sans doute qu'il n'a
pas de très bons arguments mais il sera
devant la justice vous l'avez dit il a
pu refuser pour le moment de venir
devant le Parlement mais la justice
française c'est la première entreprise
qui va être devant la justice à cause de
la loi sur le devoir de vigilance la loi
sur le devoir de vigilance il ne doit
très importante qui a été votée il y a
quelques années qui dit en gros que ce
qui n'est pas possible de faire en
France ou en Europe une entreprise n'a
pas le droit de le faire dans les pays
du Sud en pensant que ça va pas se voir
et donc c'est la première fois qu'une
entreprise est devant la justice total a
tout fait depuis deux ans pour que le
procès soit repoussé repoussé mais le 7
décembre le juge a dit maintenant on ne
décale plus il y a un arrêt de la Cour
de cassation et puis le juge encore il y
a quelques jours a dit le 7 décembre les
avocats de total seront devant répondre
à nos questions donc on va pas les
lâcher et de même la le texte du
Parlement européen mais devant la
responsabilité les actionnaires de Total
les steaksworders c'est le Crédit
Agricole c'est à Mundi le Crédit
Agricole on le dit que c'est une banque
verte c'est la banque des agriculteurs
mais en fait ce sont les premiers
financeurs et les premiers actionnaires
de Total et c'est quand même assez
choquant cet été dans tous les
départements de France les paysans
n'avaient pas assez d'eau pour leur
culture dans la plupart des départements
les paysans ont dû tuer une partie de
leur bête ou vendre une partie du
troupeau parce qu'il n'avait plus assez
d'herbe à cause de la sécheresse donc
les agriculteurs sont directement
impactés par le dérèglement climatique
et le Crédit Agricole est le premier
financeur et le premier actionnaire de
Total donc j'ai demandé rendez-vous pour
voir bientôt les patrons du Crédit
Agricole mais eux aussi ils devraient
prendre plus sérieusement leur
responsabilité et à l'heure où nous
enregistrons cette émission on a appris
aussi un nouveau projet aura étant pour
parler celui du total en Afrique du Sud
en Afrique du Sud total vraiment ce sont
les pires j'en ai honte plusieurs fois
je me suis exclus dans que comme
français j'en ai honte mais vraiment ce
sont les pires dans toutes les grandes
entreprises de pétrole ce sont les pires
pour les investissements et donc en
Afrique du Sud ils veulent faire à 150
km des côtes dans un endroit où il y a
une biodiversité marine magnifique ils
veulent forer pour trouver du gazera
pour en reparler merci beaucoup merci à
vous d'avoir été avec nous je rappelle
que vous êtes heureux débuter membre du
groupe des progressistes des socialistes
et des démocrates des députés européens
nouvelles donnent au Parlement européen
et porte-parole de nouvelles données
zone Europe sur sensation le cinéma
européen à l'honneur à présent avec le
film l'affaire collective lauréat du
Prix luxe en 2021 ce film documentaire
réalisé par Alexander nano revient sur
le tragique incendie d'une boîte de nuit
à Bucarest en Roumanie c'était en 2015
c'est la chronique de Louis break
étudiant à l'inicp
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
au coeur de ce documentaire le
journaliste et les lanceurs d'alerte un
outil pour lutter contre la corruption
qui ronge un pays une volonté affichée
par son réalisateur Alexander nano
ce qui marque avec mon film à faire
collective c'est qu'il est tourné comme
l'Europe fonctionne en réalité
comment est géré le pouvoir et la place
du journalisme en Europe car il y a de
plus en plus de corruption en Europe et
il y a besoin du journaliste pour
dénoncer cela
de plus en plus de dirigeants utilisent
trop leur pouvoir
et marche sur la vie du peuple et sont
très corrompus
life comme on a pu le voir pendant la
pandémie dans beaucoup de pays
je pense que l'affaire collective montre
ce besoin du journaliste pour protéger
la citoyenneté des Européens avec la
vérité
le pouvoir a tendance à cacher leurs
vrais intentions derrière une fausse
réalité
et le manque de confiance envers les
dirigeants et dû à l'écart entre les
dirigeants et les dirigés
en plus du prix luxe ce film a été nommé
aux Oscars dans deux catégories le
meilleur film documentaire et le
Meilleur Film International
zone Europe voyage
voyager dans l'assiette nous avons
rendez-vous avec le chef David shelman
chef du restaurant Le Coq a Bougival
dans les Yvelines vous voulez vous
proposer une recette donc une recette
emblématique de de la maison et que j'ai
toujours fait c'est le tartare de canard
pour aller au foie gras avec des petites
pommes de terre sautées avec des
champignons des petits oignons donc on a
un joli mélange de foie gras de canard
et de pommes sautées avec un de viande
alors vous allez avoir besoin comme pour
un traditionnel un petit peu d'oignon un
petit peu de câpres de cornichons de la
mayonnaise du ketchup de la ciboulette
un petit peu de Tabasco de sauce
anglaise et puis le le canard qu'on va
saisonnier comme un tartare de bœuf en
fait alors là
on a le magret qu'on va dégraisser
partiellement
voilà donc là on prépare la viande
ensuite donc vous allez hacher le canard
vous allez retrouver comme ceci
et là on va commencer à assaisonner avec
un petit peu de câpres comme ça un petit
peu cornichon on continue avec les
petits ingrédients du Tartare comme je
vous disais tout à l'heure
c'est comme un tartare de bœuf les
petites herbes fraises
je mets
une cuillère de ketchup
un petit peu de mayonnaise
ce qui va permettre de lier la viande un
petit peu donc un petit peu de Tabasco
aussi pour bien le relever place aux
anglaises
un petit peu de poivre
voilà un petit peu de fleur de sel et on
va pouvoir commencer à mélanger
voilà on mélange bien
comme je vous disais c'est vraiment
comme un
comme un tartare de bœuf
on va lui donner une petite forme
pour qu'il soit pour qu'il soit le plus
régulier possible je le Tasse un petit
peu comme ça pour lui donner la forme du
cercle je vais également couper une
belle escalope de foie gras
une petite entame voilà là je taille une
belle escalope c'est ce qui va venir
terminer